when the masters of a strange World make
the Creations too strong they rebel
against their Master using a gifted
child in an alternate world the Stars
tell the story of its creation millions
of years ago this world was ruled by the
Titans they were powerful but their
reign was ended by their own Sons named
Zeus posidon and Hades Zeus convinced
his brother Hades to create a beast so
strong it could defeat their parents and
by using his own flesh Hades gave birth
to an unspeakable horror the Kraken Zeus
became king of the heavens posidon King
of the Seas and Hades was tricked by
Zeus and was left to rule the underworld
in darkness and in misery Zeus created
humans and their prayers helped him gain
immortality many centuries passed away
like this but humans had intelligence
and they started to ponder their
existence it reached the point at which
the humans decided to defeat their
creators and rule the world themselves
in this chaos a miraculous child was
born he was thrown in water with his
mother but a fisherman found him the
woman was killed but the kid survived
the fisherman had a wife who soon gave
birth to a baby girl but the fisherman
treated the kid as his son and named him
Perseus Perseus also loved his adoptive
family and wished to live a peaceful
life several years have passed away and
persus has grown up into a young
handsome man he helps his father in
fishing but for the past few months they
are having hard luck the fisherman gets
frustrated and blames Zeus and Poseidon
for being so hard on him they destroyed
his Island created plagues and now they
are not even providing food what's the
purpose of loving them the fisherman's
wife advises him to be grateful as Zeus
gave them life but the fisherman is fed
up with this life he believes that one
day someone is going to stand against
the creators and that day a huge
Revolution will take place while sailing
in the ocean Perseus and his family
reach the Magnificent statue of Zeus
they get shocked to see that the Royal
soldiers from the Argos Island are
breaking the statue they succeed and the
statue falls in the ocean they have
declared a war against Zeus suddenly a
bunch of flying monsters rise from the
oceans and kill the soldier it is Hades
he uses solders flesh to become more
powerful and attacks perseus's ship
Perseus tries to save his family but
fails he just lays down on a plank and
moans the loss this incident is also
discussed in heaven the Titans ask Zeus
to put an end to this war the humans
first invaded the temples and now they
humiliated the sacred statue suddenly
Hades reaches there he has met his
brother after a long time but he kept an
eye on the humans he believes that Zeus
has been too soft to them which made
them stronger Hades prefers to threaten
the humans and in fear they will become
obedient once again the Titans protest
against this idea but Zeus agrees and
permits Hades to handle this matter
meanwhile Perseus gets caught by the
Argos soldiers and he is taken to the
Palace where he meets king keus and
queen Copa Kus admires his soldiers for
taking down the statue he doesn't care
about the lives that were sacrificed in
this attempt because his goal is to
starve Zeus for their prayers a new era
will begin and it will be the era of men
however the princess Andromeda feels
uneasy she dares to shout at the king
and asks him why he is celebrating when
thousands of his people have died they
have provoked Zeus and now they are
assuming that there will be no
consequences it's time to Fear The Wrath
of the Titans the queen laughs it off
and says that Zeus is the one who needs
humans he is defeated and the humans
will be the new ruler of this world
suddenly the ground starts to shake and
a dark smoke spreads around the
Soldier's flesh gets sucked by Hades as
he appears in front of the queen he
mocks his morality and kills her in an
instant then he gives Argos a final
warning they have 10 days after that
when the sun will be eclipsed Hades will
unleash the kraken the Argos will be
swept from the earth along with all its
inhabitants there's only one way to stop
it and it's the sacrifice of the
princess Hades leaves this decision to
the public and disappears suddenly a
rumor is spread that Perseus is the son
of Zeus and he is sent to help the
humans caus begs Perseus to help them as
he doesn't want to sacrifice his beloved
daughter Perseus explains that he is
just an ordinary fisherman whose family
was killed by Hades and droma reaches
there and tells everyone to not worry so
much for her she is willing to sacrifice
her life for the sake of his people but
the king doesn't allow that Perseus is
thrown into the dungeon and a mysterious
lady comes to meet him she introduces
herself as IO and claims to know
perseus's origin she has been living for
several years but a curse didn't let her
age and she saw all of her loved ones
die IO confirms that Perseus is the son
of Zeus the story of his birth began
with the rebellion of King acrus the
humans were tired of Zeus's mistreatment
so king acrus led an army to Zeus's
Throne on Olympus Mountain other Titans
wanted to punish him but Zeus wanted to
turn the king into an example he
disguised as acus and spent the night at
the Queen's chamber she miraculously
gave birth to a child instantly but the
king decided to take his revenge he took
his wife and Zeus's child to cast them
in the sea but suddenly lightning struck
him acus still continued his mission the
queen was killed but the child survived
and that half Titan child is Perseus IO
has been waiting for Perseus to grow up
and defeat the kraken he is born to help
the humans get rid of the Titans Perseus
doesn't care about this war all he wants
is to avenge his family's death by
killing Hades IO explains that he must
kill the Kraken to weaken Hades hearing
this persus agrees to fight against the
Kraken keio's Army and its leader Draco
are preparing for the battle and persus
joins them but only stigan witches know
how to kill the Kraken they live in a
forbidden place but keus is willing to
make every effort to defeat Zeus a bunch
of hunters willingly join them too and
they all head to a long and painful
Journey meanwhile Hades is secretly
planning his own Victory he wants to
avenge Zeus for the Betrayal he gave
years ago now Hades wants to to deceive
Zeus and rule the world but first of all
he must kill the son of Zeus King acrus
is living in the Underworld and he urges
to complete his revenge Hades gives him
special dark powers and orders him to
kill Perseus on the other side four days
pass away but ke's Army is still looking
for the stigan witches they stop in the
middle of a forest to rest and Drago
takes this chance to teach persio how to
fight the young man seems to have a
natural Talent even though he never
stepped in a battle the next morning
when everyone is asleep Perseus decides
to take a walk around the forest he
suddenly finds a shiny object that turns
into a powerful sword that is forged on
Olympus Draco calls it a gift of the
Titans and suggests that Perseus keep it
but Perseus wants to defeat the kraken
as a human without any help from the
Titans as he walks forward he finds a
bunch of white flying horses they all
run away in fear when they see the black
horse coming IO appears out of nowhere
and calms the horse it's called Pegasus
no one one has ever ridden one this
horse is a sign that the Titans are
watching them suddenly Perseus hears a
scream and rushes to help his mates it's
king acrus who tears apart one of the
soldiers Perseus attacks him bravely but
gets bitten on his arm the other
soldiers join him too and acrus starts
running away the Army follows him to
know his identity and they reach the
desert acrus gets defeated but a huge
scorpion emerges from the sand it tries
to kill Perseus but IO reaches there to
save him but another scorpion attacks
her once the soldiers kill those
scorpions more of them appear out of
nowhere fortunately a group of
mysterious mummies saved them they are
the Jin the desert belongs to them keus
and Men follow the Gin but Perseus can't
walk anymore the Venom from acrus bite
is killing him IO takes him to a shelter
and gives him some water when she leaves
one of the mummies sneaks in and does
magic on persus he starts crying in pain
so the soldiers start attacking the
mummy IO stops them and translates what
the mummy is saying the Jin have waited
many years for the one who will free
them from the gods they want to join
hands and defeat the kraken together
with kipus Perseus is cured by their
magic and convinces Draco to accept the
deal they all rest for the night and the
next morning they prepare to continue
their Journey Draco reminds persus that
a normal human can never defeat the
kraken so he should accept his identity
and take its full advantage persus is
still being stubborn but Draco advises
him to use the Olympus sword if the need
arrives after a while jyn reaches there
with the Scorpions he has gained control
over them and made them slaves everyone
rides the Scorpions to reach their
destination The Garden of sagia this is
the place where the krens defeated the
Titans IO advises persus to only ask the
necessary questions from the witches as
they can make unavoidable prophecies the
stigan witches are creepy creatures with
no eyes all they get is one eyeball
which they carry in their hands they
refuse to cooperate and attack the the
soldiers Perseus plays cleverly and
snatches the eyeball he threatens to
destroy it if the witches don't help
them the plan works and witches reveal
that the Kraken can be defeated with the
help of Medusa her gaze can turn anyone
into stone she will not willingly help
for sure so they must cut her head to
use it against the Kraken this will not
be easy and moreover she lives in a
palace near the edge of the underworld
despite these circumstances pereus is
willing to continue his mission
unfortunately Perseus forgets what IO
said and stops when the witches decide
to tell him something more they trick
him to make a prophecy According to
which Perseus will die in this journey
Perseus gets a little worried and walks
out first he meets Zeus who is dressed
up as a regular man he introduces
himself and offers pereus to join the
Titans but Perseus wants to live as a
human humans don't do everything for the
sake of their creator they fight and die
for each other seeing his dedication
Zeus lets Perseus continue his mission
and also gives a gold coin Perseus joins
the soldiers who have made a special
shield for him they believe that Perseus
can prove the prophecy wrong they head
to the edge of the underworld and jyn
throws the gold coin in the water it
summons a ship that carries them to
Medusa's Palace on the way IO tells them
more about Medusa she was a beautiful
woman who made posidon fall for her to
escape him Medusa hid in the Athena
Temple and prayed for help but Poseidon
found her and abused her brutally Medusa
went to the Athena goddess for Comfort
but the goddess felt disgusted and made
Medusa undesirable for an eternity she
can't harm women so only men are allowed
in her Palace but no one came back alive
IO also teaches Perseus some tricks to
deal with Medusa as he can't look at her
directly on reaching the palace the
soldiers spread around to find Medusa
but got killed one by one whoever looks
at her face turns into stone even jyn
and Draco sacrifice themselves to save
Perseus afterwards he uses the shiny
Shield to see Medusa indirectly and
succeeds in cutting off her head when he
gets out of the palace he finds IO
caught by acrus he attacks her brutally
and proceeds to fight Perseus with no
other option left Perseus finally uses
the Olympus sword to defeat acrus he
rushes back to IO and refuses to leave
her side but IO advises him to go and
save the world he is half human and half
Titan so he got the best part of both
saying this IO disintegrates into light
suddenly Pegasus reaches there and
offers pereus a ride meanwhile Hades
goes back to heaven and he convinces
Zeus to release the Kraken once it's
done Hades Reveals His True Colors he
created Kraken and only he can control
him Zeus's Reign is over the Kraken
emerges from the ocean and proceeds
towards Argos the public ties up the
princess to sacrifice her life but it's
already too late when everyone has lost
hope the hero emerges Perseus arrives
riding Pegasus Hades tries to stop him
with his flying monsters but Perseus
defeats all of them and faces the Kraken
before the Beast can attack Perseus
takes Medusa's head and turns the Kraken
into a stone statue it breaks down and
falls in the ocean afterwards persus
proceeds to take his reveng he uses the
Olympus sword combined with Zeus's
gifted power to defeat Hadis and send
him back to the underworld then he
rushes to save the princess she offers
him to become argos's ruler but he
prefers being a normal man Zeus comes
down again to reward Perseus but he is
still not willing to become a Titan
Hades is still alive waiting for humans
to get weak so he can Rise Again Perseus
wants to be an example of the power of
humans seeing his dedication Zeus lets
him stay but gives him a present anyway
he reincarnates low